Speaker 1: All right, I am going to talk about
the absolutely horrifying situation involving
the actor, Alec Baldwin, who accidentally shot
someone to death on the set of the film Rust,
it's it's almost an inconceivable headline.
Actor Alec Baldwin shot someone to death and
injured another person with a gun. On the set of
a movie. But that's what happened. And over the
weekend we've gotten. I guess I would like to say
some more clarity, although it's still not exactly
clear what happened down to the detail, but we
have increasingly a general understanding of
it. So let's look at the latest report from
The Associated Press. An assistant director
unwittingly handed Alec Baldwin a loaded
weapon and told him it was safe to use
in the moments before the actor fatally shot
a cinematographer called Gun. The assistant
director announced, according to a search warrant
filed in a Santa Fe court. Instead, the gun was
loaded with live rounds, and when Baldwin pulled
the trigger Thursday on the set of a western, he
killed cinematographer Halina Hutchins. Director
Joel Souza, standing behind her, was wounded.
The Santa Fe County Sheriff's Office obtained the
warrant Friday, so investigators could document
the scene at the ranch outside Santa Fe, where
the shooting took place. They sought to examine
Baldwin's bloodstained costume for the film
Rust, as well as the weapon that was fired.
Other prop guns, ammunition and footage that
might exist. The gun was one of three that
the film's armorer, Hannah Gutierrez, had set
on a cart outside the wooden structure where a
scene was being acted. Assistant director
Dave Halls grabbed the gun from the cart,
brought it inside to Baldwin, unaware it was
loaded with live rounds. It was unclear how
many rounds were fired. Gutierrez removed a
shell casing from the gun after the shooting,
and she turned the weapon over to police when they
arrived. Hulls did not immediately return phone
and email messages. The AP was unable to contact
Gutierrez. Several messages sent to production
companies were not immediately returned. The
film's script supervisor, Mamie Mitchell,
said she was standing next to Hutchins when she
was shot. I ran out and called 9-1-1 and said,
Bring everybody, send everybody. This woman
is gone at the beginning of her career.
Mitchell said she and other crew members
were attending a private memorial service.
Baldwin described the killing as a tragic
accident. There are no words to convey my
shock and sadness regarding the tragic accident
that took the life of Holiness Hutchins, a wife,
mother and deeply admired colleague of ours. I am
fully cooperating with the police investigation.
My heart is broken for her husband, their son
and all who knew and loved Helena. No charges
immediately filed. I know that the New York Post,
for example, which is a Fox News Corporation slash
Fox News publication, has been talking about
manslaughter charges against Baldwin. If you
look at the article, it's sort of like based on
what one legal expert theorizes, it's speculative.
We just don't know about that at this point in
time. The question that's not been answered is
why were there any live rounds on the set? And
initially there was the belief that there was
a blank and you can you can hurt someone with
a blank if you're right next to them that this
was a blank and a tragedy, an accident involving a
blank. Now we've learned at least it's being said
it was a live round. And so then the question
is why were there live rounds there? There may
be some explanation. But we have not yet gotten an
answer, another article from CNN Russell director,
told authorities. Alec Baldwin was practicing
drawing his gun when the weapon discharged.
The shot that killed the cinematographer on a New
Mexico film set last week was fired as actor Alec
Baldwin was practicing drawing his gun, according
to the director who was injured in the shooting.
Listen, I know that there are people who because
Alec Baldwin is a left winger and played Trump on
Saturday Night Live and there's a lot of right
wing people angry. They just hate Alec Baldwin.
They are saying Alec Baldwin has committed a crime
or is to blame here. Now you can slice and dice
this a lot of different ways. Like, for example,
there was one argument that that went like,
I'm going to give you the argument. This is
not my argument. And it was. Alec Baldwin is
ultimately to blame because even if someone else
made a mistake by putting a live round in a gun.
Even if someone else made a mistake by handing
Alec Baldwin a hot gun and saying it's a cold gun,
Alec Baldwin shouldn't even have had his finger
on the trigger. Like what if you're on set
and you're practice, you just never put your
finger on the trigger period. So ultimately, it's
Alec Baldwin's fault. It strikes me as a bit of a
stretch. If an investigation reveals Alec Baldwin
should be charged with something, I'm not going to
get in the way, believe me. But my instinct is why
was there a live round at all? And if there was,
why was Alec Baldwin given a gun allegedly and
told that it was a cold gun, not a hot gun? That's
my initial reaction now in terms of what this does
to Alec Baldwin now psychologically for the rest
of his life. I can't even imagine I'm not saying
he's the victim. I'm not calling him a victim. But
if he was given a gun and told this is a colt gun
and it has a live round and then now you've killed
someone, it's I mean, just it's impossible to
even think about. It's impossible to even
even conceive of. And so there's going to
be an investigation at some point we will know
more. We've already seen in the first few days
ago it was could have been a blank. It was an
accident with a blank. No, it was a live round.
At one point, both stories were were out. There's
going to be more information coming and we'll wait
and see what that is. But just a horrifying
situation and a tragedy. Because someone was
killed and someone was injured. It would be bad
enough if there was just an accident with a gun
on a set. This is now beyond that, and
it's a tragic accident as life was lost,
and I'm curious to hear what folks in the audience
think and I for me. Alec Baldwin's politics played
no role in my assessment of this whatsoever.
None whatsoever. Curious to hear from you